es ist der perfekte abend für ein
romantisches date im freien einen
heiratsantrag oder eine super mysteriöse
grillparty mit freunden die dann in
einer full red moon party endet denn
zunächst wird der gigantische sommer
vollmond auf gehen bevor er sich dann
blutrot färbt und das ist nicht nur eine
gewöhnliche totale mondfinsternis
sondern sogar die längste des ganzen
jahrhunderts was genau passiert und wann
und wo ihr das himmelsspektakel am
besten verfolgen könnt das alles jetzt
den klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen
genauer gesagt heute abend wird es der
fall sein
der vollmond wird aufgehen wenn die
sonne noch gar nicht richtig
untergegangen ist kurz vor 21 uhr aber
wundert euch nicht so richtig nach
vollmond sieht er nicht aus
denn ungefähr die hälfte der mond
scheibe ist schon vom schatten der erde
bedeckt und so wird eine eher
ungewöhnliche mondsichel am himmel zu
sehen sein
die schrumpft dann in den nächsten 30
minuten ziemlich zusammen gewalt
nordwestlicher man sich befindet desto
länger dauert es bis der mond am himmel
erscheint insgesamt wird sich das
himmelsspektakel eine ungewöhnlich lange
zeit hinziehen expertinnen und experten
rechnen mit einer totalen mondfinsternis
von 21 30 bis 23 uhr 15
und kurz vor 11 uhr 30 ist die
mondscheibe das schon fast komplett vom
erdschatten bedeckt ab jetzt ist der
typisch blutrote und riesengroße mond zu
bewundern in diesem zustand wird der
mond auch als blutmond bezeichnet der
grund die erde schiebt sich zwischen
mond und sondern wirft ihren schatten
auf den mond bis sie ihn ganz verdeckt
die erde kommt also die sonnenstrahlen
ab doch einige werden von der
erdatmosphäre gebrochen und zum mond
geworfen das sind langweilige
lichtstrahlen und auch infrarotstrahlen
und die liegen halt im roten bereich und
die geben dem mond diese geheimnisvolle
gestalt des blutmond ist etwas korrekter
als die bezeichnung mondfinsternis wäre
hier also so etwas wie mond rötung der
begriff blutmond deutet es ja schon an
übrigens ist der mond dann gar nicht so
groß wie es scheint tatsächlich handelt
es sich um den kleinsten vollmond des
jahres denn er hat auf seiner bahn um
die erde gerade den größten abstand zu
uns und das ist auch die erklärung für
die lange dauer der mond
dann ist doch die horizont nähe sorgt
für eine optische täuschung bezüglich
seiner größe im direkten vergleich zur
landschaft oder gebäuden sieht er eben
deutlich größer aus damit er die
mondfinsternis auch wirklich in vollen
zügen genießen können
sucht euch einen erhöhten standort mit
blick nach osten bis süden wichtig ist
die freie sicht zum horizont
denn die mondscheibe wandert von ost
südost in den süden und steigt etwa zwei
handbreit über den horizont doch sogar
ein haus oder ein wald im blickfeld
könnten euch dann die sicht verhageln
denn zum höhepunkt der mondfinsternis
befindet sich der rote blutmond nur eine
handbreit hoch achtet außerdem darauf
dass ich möglichst wenig licht wählen um
euch herum befinden
denn in der zunehmenden dämmerung
während der mondfinsternis sind
sternenhimmel und sogar die milchstraße
dann besonders gut zu erkennen die in
berlin ist das nicht so leicht aber auf
dem land da sind dann sogar gestirne zu
erkennen die sonst vom mond überstrahlt
werden zu sehen sind über dem mond
übrigens das sternbild adler und um ihn
herum die sternbilder wassermann und
steinbock schien heller als alle anderen
sterne ringsherum wird aber der mars
sein den er schon in der frühen
dämmerung beobachten können er steht
genau in opposition zur sonne also ihr
gegenüber auf der milchstraße werdet ihr
auch den saturn schimmern sehen also im
hintergrund die milchstraße davor der
saturn und ab 23 15 bis etwa 130 wird
sich die mondscheibe langsam wieder aus
dem kernschatten der erde herausschieben
ab etwa 1 uhr 30 nachts steht sie dann
wieder als vollmond scheibe am himmel
das alles mal vorausgesetzt es ist gutes
wetter und der himmel ist unbedeckt dann
ist das himmelsspektakel nicht nur in
deutschland und im restlichen europa
sondern auch in südamerika in afrika in
asien und australien zu sehen und wer
übrigens noch mal eine solche
konstellation sehen möchte der muss
105.000 jahre warten also bisher saturn
maß und so weiter alles dann auch sehen
wir vielleicht dann doch besser heute
abend anschauen und wenn ihr in zukunft
kein video von mir verpassen wollte
übrigens täglich dann endet mich bei
whatsapp dann um gibt er die ein wenig
unzuverlässige abo box hier auf youtube
und ihr verpasst kein video denn über
whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir persönlich
von jenem upload und zwar noch vor allen
an
täglich um garantiert einfach hier
draufklicken und am besten auch meinen
schwesterkanal klicks um social media
abonnieren
da gibt es das neueste aus der social
media welt dafür je klingen aber nicht
die genau geht locker vergessen
und hier geht es weiter dafür auch
draufklicken mit mondstation eishöhlen
auf dem mond entdeckt bis dann bleib
dran